now if you've been following the news
recently you'll probably have heard that
the economy is actually starting to perk
up a bit at least on a global basis and
we've just got the latest figures from
the international monetary fund and I
want to show you what they're saying
this is for the global economy so Global
growth and last time around this is what
they were forecasting so 2.7 this year
3.2 next year look at how they've
changed with their latest forecast that
bar that latest bar has gone up actually
a fair bit when you're talking about the
global economy 0.2 percentage points
that's quite an upgrade because things
are looking better inflation might have
peaked it's a pretty good news story but
I'm afraid it doesn't get so good when
you look at the UK so this is just
breaking it down looking at Major
economies around the world and just how
fast they're growing in this year so
2023 and last time around this is the
forecast from last time around the UK
was expected to have 0.3 percent growth
just look at how that's changed with
these latest updates look look at the
Red Bar
it's gone all the way down to the bottom
no longer positive territory now it's
0.6 contraction so basically it's
pointing towards a recession in the UK
and it is the worst in the G7 this is
the G7 group of uh major industrialized
economies from Japan all the way through
to the UK you see the UK is by far and
away the worst and actually when you
look at all of the economies so all
major economies the IMF is surveying
look down there there's the UK 0.6 and
not only is it the worst hit it is
actually worse than Russia so Russia
there with 0.3 growth the UK minus 0.6
it's pretty striking isn't it and I'm
afraid it's not a very good news story
when you look at the following year as
well 2024 as well the UK down there at
the bottom actually joint worst with
Italy and Japan why is all of this
happening well the IMF says it's
basically because you've got the
government raising taxes you've got
fiscal consolidation as they call it and
the bank of England raising interest
rates at the same time add it all up and
I'm afraid well it's good news for the
global economy it's not very good news
for the UK economy